[Music]
so it was 45 years ago that they had
10-cent beer night in Cleveland multiple
streakers at the game there was a riot
in the ninth inning the Indians forfeit
of the game Cleveland did another
10-cent beer night a month later thank
the person who made that decision was
still drunk from the last ten-centimeter
night so that was an idea gone horribly
wrong and we will always turn to other
sports for inspiration for our PFT live
drafts so today's draft NFL ideas gone
wrong not as wrong as 10-cent beer night
but ideas that were just bad bad ideas
so Chris I know you're ready for this
one I know you've done your research and
you're locked and loaded and and go
ahead and lose the coin toss so I can
make an excellent first pick you're a
jerk and go with tails thank you
and the rid coin toss is away and as
usual it's back it's back to being
rigged in your favor all right Chris
what do you got I know you're ready for
this oh yeah you're such a jerk okay I
think we're gonna do this in the draft I
thought this was might be a segment that
I threw out on group decks all right
first one I'm gonna do is I don't even
know what year this was okay I'm
throwing it out there you saw it on my
text message last night the Chicago
Bears fan who jumped out of the stands
to catch the the field goal against the
Green Bay Packers I I believe it was
1995 okay Monday Night Football game I
don't know do we have the clip guys by
any chance it just does or do it I just
want to make sure but either way here we
go
this is oh I'm gonna catch on an NFL
field goal kick that's gonna be amazing
guys watch me do this watch me do it he
jumps out of the stadium or out of the
out of the stands and catches an extra
point now I don't know how many beers he
was on or whatever and now here he's
trying to justify like oh I'm gonna stay
in the in the stadium and it looks like
they're trying to kick him out what I'm
amazed by is that he could still walk I
thought for sure you have like a bruised
but bone or tailbone or anything like
that but to me that's kind of like
football idea gone wrong that's one of
those moments you've got two beers three
beers in the stands and it sounds good
until you under the realize you're gonna
get arrested and you're going to jail
I think that's Doug Flutie it looks like
Doug Flutie how can you call it a bad
idea it was awesome I remember seeing it
live if he had broken his leg and the
bone was sticking out then you'd say
it's a bad idea I think it was awesome
there's never been anything like it
before there's never been anything like
it again you remember it yeah 20 plus
years later right because it was bad you
remember because it was awesome I
thought that was a great moment otally
transparent I didn't realize that he was
okay after it I thought that he you know
I I didn't realize we're gonna have
video of him running around the stands
afterwards you know I was gonna you
thought you thought he went splat
exactly I was gonna play the fact that
he's probably hurt and he's got you know
some issues in the lower body and all
that so that pround of proved me wrong
right there so I got nothing to say in
defense of that alright here's my pick
you know I would have made this pick
even if I had won the coin toss this was
a good idea for the NFL gone horribly
wrong replacement officials in 2012
leading up to the lockout of the real
officials we heard time and again from
the commissioner how the the
replacements will be every bit as good
as the real officials and that lasted
three weeks and it culminated in the
fail marry play Monday night in Seattle
Green Bay and the Seahawks the blatant
push off by Golden Tate in the end zone
even though they have different rules
for pass interference on Hail Mary we
know that now thanks to rich McKay even
what Golden Tate did should have been
called it was blatant it was obvious and
it took a win away from the Green Bay
Packers in the 2012 season and it ended
the lockout of the officials so
replacement officials a horrible idea by
the NFL and the NFL eventually had to
acknowledge it and bring the real
officials back after the film replay
that was it was it was horrible
you know all the games during that those
first two weeks of that season we're
horrible altogether but that was just
the the end capper I mean clearly an
interception and you're gonna give a
touchdown to the guy who
Don you know as the guys falling gonna
crash
it's unbelievable put eight shoves the
guy out of the way right just blatant
and but now what you know what I guess I
can understand if the replacement
officials are being told by their
supervisors hey there's no Mary then now
I understand why they screwed it up yeah
because they're telling us pass
interference all of a sudden isn't pass
interference so a Golden Tate just did
maybe it's not a foul after all all
right Chris you're up around 2:00 okay
I'm going to week six 2015 hatreds cults
okay you want to talk about you know
good football ideas gone wrong oh you
know a we're gonna have something in the
bag to to help us beat the New England
Patriots we're gonna throw a curve ball
at them do whatever it may be
well its fourth down in the third
quarter the Colts are only down by three
points anybody that you know was
watching football the times got to
remember this play Colts lineup in some
crazy fake punt formation right hoping
to get the proper look they want okay
they got the safety and I think Whalen
like the backup receivers snapping the
ball they don't have the look that they
need to get the first down and it's
fourth and three and it is literally one
blocker verse three defenders and they
decide to snap the ball and of course
lose two yards that is one of those that
whoa the idea was great during the week
the execution the moment the
communication everything about it and
there's our dude
that to me was one that stuck out in my
brain pretty early on when we talked
about this and you know I like that and
I remember thinking at the time that the
Chuck Pagano is trying to get fired
because he was on the hot seat at the
time and it's like what in the world are
you doing if and I remember wale and
screwed up he say he wasn't supposed to
snap a bail he was not me right right
and and and there it went all right my
mind is it's a big picture one that
actually lasted for a few years and I
still can't believe in hindsight the NFL
actually did this remember when there
would be a penalty for excessive crowd
noise do you
yes the crowd was too loud that first
you would get a warning and then and
then they would actually administer a
penalty against the home team because
God forbid the fans were too loud you
want the fans to be passionate you want
them to be loud and I remember at the
time as they were like when I would
watch the games like there is something
weird about this you that's what
football is about it's about instilling
and stirring that kind of reaction and
and be loud but don't be too loud you
can be loud but not too loud and and I
just I'm so glad that they realized oh
how long that thing last like it lasted
longer than it did but that was a
disaster
that was truly one of the dumbest things
in the history of sports Mike that is
such a great pick by you and I had
forgotten about this altogether but well
what's the point of playing at home if
you don't have a home field advantage I
can remember going to one of my dad's
games in 1988 against the Los Angeles
Rams Jim Everett this Giants fans so
loud it was one of the loudest times I
ever heard it and you know the Rams were
this passing team they like to be in the
shotgun and a lot the fans got so loud
that guess what
the offensive line couldn't hear Jim
Everett say the snap count from 6 yards
away and the shotgun shocker
with 75,000 people in the stands and
yeah there had to be a number of stops
during the game to tell the fans to be
quiet I mean that really was that was so
dumb I don't even know what to say about
it it actually makes me kind of angry as
I'm sitting here talking about it it was
that stupid so great pick by you you
might have just won the draft with that
one right there I'm not even gonna lie
I'm not gonna lie today as you know I
did not expect us to have the draft
until we started the show so here we go
what do you have Rob you've done all
right for a guy who was completely
unprepared what do you have for round
three round three I mean there's a few
things I want to go here I'm gonna be
transparent I mean I kind of want to go
with like I'm thinking about you know
the Browns building a stadium by Lake
Erie I mean that's one of those things
oh it's great real estate oh gosh the
weather's bad here it's hard to kick a
field goal or throw a ball I kind of
want to do that but I'm gonna go with
something a little more fun to me at
least the San Francisco 49ers going back
to black cleats okay I
understand this I've argued our I've
made my points clear to my friend Kyle
Shanahan about this before too but the
49ers wear black cleats right now Mike
when they lost their Super Bowl to the
Baltimore Ravens they were wearing black
cleats I don't get it first of all their
uniform doesn't have any black in it
okay so that's the one thing I want to
argue second of all they've won five
Super Bowls wearing white cleats why the
hell are they wearing black cleats
that's just one of those ideas where
it's just like oh we're gonna go back to
our original look of the 19 late 1960s
early 1970s and have that old fashioned
style look I mean I know this is silly
altogether but I mean I just look at
that and go man I would change it just
on principle right there let's see five
and Oh with Super Bowl wins and white
cleats only been to one Super Bowl all
the other years and black cleats and
lost it when they were probably the
better team on the field that day so
that's just one that jumps out to me
well and here's the thing you know it
sounds extremely superficial but players
care about this no yeah right and they
don't like wearing black cleats because
black cleats make them look slower than
they are definitely exactly right
there's part of a uniform is part of the
psyche you know I mean hey think about
the Denver Broncos right I mean they
couldn't win the Superbowl change the
uniforms gave the whole organization a
different outlook all of a sudden they
won two in a row the New England
Patriots you know look at what they did
Bill Parcells comes around you know
changes a uniform a little bit all of a
sudden they're in the Super Bowl they're
a perennial contender every year so
those kind of things can change the
outlook and the feel and the aura of an
organization I truly do believe that
well didn't you say that without you
even when you were a backup quarterback
you'd always make sure that the look was
good before you left the locker you look
good look good feel good I always used
to hear Jerry Rice say that and yeah I
mean I do I was holding the clipboard
but I wanted to look good doing it on
the sideline all right last one for me
and this is a landslide and hey you know
I got to take him where I can get him
the Greg Schiano blowing up a victory
formation and and that look I I'm not
seeing Greg Schiano would still be an
NFL coach right now but early in his
time with Tampa Bay
I remember he got Tom Coughlin's the
coach of the Johnson time very upset
with him the idea that the game is over
you're just taking a couple of knees and
all of a sudden the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
players at the direction of Greg Schiano
are diving into the legs of the Giants
offensive lineman to try to force a
fumble and get the ball back and it was
a bad look it was a violation of
whatever unwritten rules are out there
and I think it created a sense from the
outset that Greg Schiano is not fit to
be an NFL head coach and he only made it
two years in that role because of that
now winning games would have made a
difference but that's the thing if
you're gonna do that kind of stuff you'd
better win all your games or they're
gonna get rid of you and it just created
a very negative outset of a career for
Greg Shawn I remember the after the show
we used to do in the afternoons I
interviewed him for that show and he was
getting a little salty about being asked
questions about that that dynamic he was
done talking about it because he took so
much criticism for it and there's a
reason no one else has ever done it he's
the only one who's ever done it that
shows you what a bad idea it is yeah it
was you know hey Greg Schiano
you know first of all to be totally
transparent went to my high school I
know the guy he's a head coach yeah you
know it he's tough he's no-nonsense you
know he was coached by my old high
school coach Mike me yellow who was a
guy that you know followed the steps of
Vince Lombardi and all that the games
never over we're gonna play tough to the
very end so that was part of his
thinking there yes but it's not cut out
for professional football that way it's
not and - what you're saying - you know
it did catch on a little bit with a few
teams here and there and I even see in
college football every now and then to
where teams had to stop putting the
quarterback underneath the center in
those scenarios and almost get back into
a shotgun let's snap the ball back from
there and protect them type of formation
but ya got no place in in the game and
you can hurt hurt people in those type
of situations and franchise quarterbacks
can get hurt and be done for the year
with that kind of stuff we're way over
we got to take a break we'll wrap up
this Wednesday edition of PFC live right
after this
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports